hey guys Pete here the first mr. robot
season 4 trailer has finally dropped and
there's a lot of interesting shots to
discuss here it seems like it's been
about two years since I made it mr.
robot video so this is pretty exciting
I'll break the trailer down scene by
scene but we have some other information
and a release date to talk about first
mr. robot season 4 will premiere on
October 6th and The Hollywood Reporter
is saying that there will be 13 episodes
in total in the past we've had two
episodes released together on the
premieres and the finale so we can't say
for sure when mr. robot will officially
end its run season 2 was 12 episodes
which means this is the longest season
of the series the air date for mr. robot
has always been on Wednesdays but this
has been changed in season four looks to
be airing on Sunday nights it's all
exciting and a bit sad at the same time
so let's break down the trailer scene by
scene and discuss what it might all mean
the season for trailers opening scene is
of the New York Stock Exchange it's
Christmas time in New York and the
show's timeline puts us in 2015
considering the series creator Sam SML
has described this season as one long
Christmas special keeping with that
theme we see what I think is an outdoor
skating rink at Bryant Park in New York
City and the background music is silent
night which is a nice touch these first
two shots have a blur effect around the
edges which is noticeable this could be
just an added effect since it's the
beginning of the first trailer but it
could also be a nod to the Leon recap
where he mentions the ending of State
elsewhere I seriously doubt there's any
chance that mr. robot will turn out to
be someone's dream so I sort of chuckled
to myself when I made that connection
because basically Leon was saying that
it wouldn't happen that way the next
shot is on the subway where we see some
in-world ads for the bank of E a
character dressed as Santa Claus was the
Christmas tree sitting on the seat next
to him and we get our first look at
Elliott and mr. robot side-by-side they
both looked deep in thought and to me
mr. robot looks conflicted about
whatever it is he's thinking about the
next thought is a strange one we see a
character in a black hoodie walking down
a hallway just as the voice over between
Elliott and mr. robot begins Elliott
says we need to get back to work the
hallway it looks to me like it could be
washington township plant and the blue
jeans in the shot stick out like a sore
thumb this
doesn't look like anything we've seen
Eliot where it makes you take a closer
look and when you do this doesn't really
look like rami malek from behind like
his body type looks off to me so my gut
feeling is that this isn't Eliot walking
down the hall the very next scene is at
night somewhere outside the city there's
a mist in the air and snow on the ground
the first time I watch this I thought it
might be herbing but it doesn't really
make sense it would actually make a lot
more sense if it was Tyrell some of the
preseason images we've seen make that
the most likely bet and you have to
wonder where Tyrell would be headed
alone on a country road late at night
after that we cut to the allsafe offices
which look to be a new base of
operations for Eliot and F Society we
see that no one has moved into the space
since allsafe folded mr. robot is at the
terminal with Eliot pacing in the
background we see a social media profile
up on the screen which means they're
looking for someone to exploit or
looking for a way to exploit someone and
I've seen some people mention online
that this is Ali's profile that he's
looking at I can't find a screenshot of
it to independently confirm this so for
now it stands as a maybe
one way or the other they're working
together in this scene and that is also
notable we catch a glimpse of Darlene
next she's standing on the street and
everyone around her seems to be
panicking or running from something or
towards something it stands out that
she's not in a hurry at all while
everyone else is she also looks deep in
thought the voice-over picks up again
and this time mr. robot says you go down
this path it'll never end while he's
saying that we get a sequence that
includes a dead body being put into an
ambulance outside of a New York City
apartment building there's no indication
who was on the stretcher but the fact
that the head is covered would indicate
that they are deceased then we see white
rose dressed as Minister Jang on a
staircase looking back at something
can't really say for certain where this
is but he looks to be giving something a
second thought and we can see that he
has some escorts going along with him
that cuts to have seen the Darlene and
what looks like a dressing room it's a
strange shot where we see her clothes a
curt there are look like props filling
the room beyond it and the scene ends on
the F Society mask which is hanging on
something and it's surrounded by other
masks it's really hard to make out
what's actually going on here mr. robot
continues saying there will always be
something else
so another symbol to destroy more people
to save this is an endless war as he's
talking we see a different shot of
Elliot in the all safe offices this
looks like he might be arriving there
for the first time there's also a shot
of the entrance of the evil Corp
building in that we see a man walking up
to approach the building the most likely
candidate here is Phillip price based on
the gray hair but to me this person
looks like he's wearing street clothes
rather than a suit it could still be
price but I don't think it's likely that
the Acting CEO of the corporation would
come to work dressed down so it's
possible he's coming back to the office
after being terminated or something like
that
either way it's a beautiful-looking shot
and we see that there is no longer any
protesters hanging around outside the
building of course at the end of season
3 Elliot reversed the hack so things
could potentially all be going back to
normal there's a quick shot of a black
body bag being zipped shut it's an
extreme close-up so all we can see is
the person who's closing the bag is
wearing black gloves in the next scene
we see Elliot rushing down a staircase
with the female character following
behind
Elliot happens to be wearing black
gloves here but I don't think it's
connected to the body bag shot he's
wearing his hoodie and the sleeves and
the last shot looked like a jacket the
woman following him is probably Darlene
wearing a wig based on a photo
Carly taken posted on her Instagram
during filming but we can't say for sure
the staircase itself looks interesting
to me it's somewhat narrow and has
industrial looking metal railings I'm
not sure what that means but it doesn't
look like a staircase that the general
public would use kind of like has this
back staircase kind of feel to it or a
staircase in some kind of work area or
something along those lines in the next
scene we get our first glimpse of dom ms
de Pierrot is in the front yard of what
looks like a more suburban house we see
that it's a big house it has a yard and
there's a nativity scene set up in the
front
she turns with the concerned look on her
face that is really similar to the looks
we see on all the other character spaces
but she turns to the camera which also
mirrors the shot we saw of Joan from
there we cut to a shot of Krista who is
actually smiling she doesn't have a
concerned look on her face at all well
at least not at first then wait a minute
her smile turns to concern so that cuts
to a shot of Darlene
crying on a bed the walls here remind me
of Angela's apartment after she went off
the deep end in season three she sort of
took dark paint and rolled it
haphazardly over the white but the
layout in this shot doesn't seem to
match up with anything I saw there so
I'm not really sure if that's where
she's at
we then see a bloody screen making a
call with Chinese characters that would
seemingly connect this to the dark army
in one way or another we see the word
signal which could be related to the
encrypted signal app and my best guess
about the characters is that therefore
some word that are related to making a
call as and it's not as somebody's name
with a contacts name but it's describing
what the phone is doing Chinese speakers
feel free to correct me if I'm wrong
there Eliot's being grabbed up by some
guys wearing suits after that he's
fighting against this but there aren't
many details we can pick up here this is
followed by someone writing they're
listening on a yellow legal pad which
could be anywhere or related to the next
shot in that next shot we see Tyrell and
Elliot together in Elliott's apartment
it looks like they're startled by
something outside the window as they
both sort of turn in that direction it's
good to see these two together but it's
a quick scene so we'll have to wait and
see what's happening here after that we
get a really good looking scene that is
equally mysterious there's a bouquet of
white roses smeared with blood and a man
wearing a white tuxedo jacket bleeding
out on the floor I can't make out his
face and there's another dark-haired man
leaning over him the dark hair could
indicate that this is an Asian man most
likely Chinese but they were kind of
careful to make it so you can't see
what's going on the flowers reminded me
of this playing card that showed up in
the promotional materials and the Arg
stuff last season it says together we
will bathe the white rose in red this
shot looks to be meticulously set up
with the way the tables arranged and the
light shining down from the window and
it makes it a lot more frustrating that
you can't make out who's on the ground
I highly doubt this is White Rose or at
least that they would give her death
scene away in the trailer but I guess we
don't know if the gun shot will turn out
to be fatal or not the bouquet itself to
decor of the room the items on the table
and the fact that both characters are
dressed in formal attire and that this
shooting took place in a high-class
establishment one of the guesses I've
seen online is that this is Irving based
on there possibly being a mustache and
glasses involved but it's really
to see the face and I don't know we have
any solid evidence that would tie
herbing to a location like this it's
possible but I can't really tell who it
is from the shot and I've seen basically
everybody's name inserted into that and
comment on different things online so
your guess is as good as mine
the next shot we see someone pouring
what looks like drugs into a spoon
considering it as a spoon and there's
water sitting next to it it kind of
looks like someone's getting ready to
inject heroin of course I guess you
could use these same items to inject any
number of drugs so it's just a guess we
know Elliot struggled with morphine
addiction in the past there's a definite
possibility that he might graduate to
something stronger and more readily
available we've seen them have trouble
finding morphine in the past after
watching the trailer over and over it
also hit me that if you wanted to kill a
guy like Elliot and you wanted to make
it look like an accident then this would
be a pretty good way to do it and the
person who's dumping the powder in the
spoon is clearly wearing black gloves we
also have beer or returning which is a
character we've seen using and selling
hard drugs so this could also be related
to him things pick up after that as we
get a shot of Elliot on a bus that is
being stopped by a police cruiser that's
blocking the road Elliot looks ready to
take off he looks like he's gonna run to
the back of the bus maybe from there he
jumps off and a foot chase ensues and
that's probably related to some of the
behind the scenes stuff we saw during
the season for filming after that we get
our first close-up look at Phillip price
he's having a meal slash meeting with
someone and we see him look up and take
notice of something the person across
from him says the bottle of wine on the
table looks similar to the bottle on the
table next to the white roses so those
two scenes could take place in the same
building it's kind of a stretch though
because wine labels obviously could
resemble each other pretty easily
mr. robots voiceover continues and he
says what you're about to do is crossing
a line this is interesting and I'll come
back to that later but but as he's
saying that we see someone throw Darlene
into a bathroom the walls here again
have that strange dark paint rolled over
white walls which means this could be
connected to the scene where we saw her
on the bed but she's wearing a sweater
here in this shot this leads us into a
shot of beer holding a phone and
shooting a gun it looks like he's in a
kitchen based on the whisk
that we see hanging next to him he looks
absolutely casual as he shoots the gun
and what looks like an execution and the
phone makes me think he's filming it to
prove that the deed is done
like he's doing it for someone so he
needs proof that he actually went
through with it and completed it the
next thought is to only look about
Angela that we get in the trailer and it
looks like it's taken from a scene in
season 3 when she's in Elliot's
apartment when Leone showed up there
it's odd that they would recycle the
only glimpse that we get AB Angela but
it does appear to be from that scene to
me so there's probably a reason why
they're holding back new footage of
Angela I know I saw a lot of people
wandering online if maybe they killed
her off she wasn't posting a lot of
stuff on social media about filming and
that led to a bunch of speculation but
there's also a lot of other reasons why
they might not show her in the very
first trailer so I'm not gonna jump to
that conclusion yet she's a pretty
essential character so there would be
some explaining to do in order for them
to get rid of her altogether we see
Elliot running down the street after
dark but can't see who if anyone is
chasing after him that leads into
another mysterious scene where we seen
masked men coming into someone's home we
see them grab a child and then toss
someone over a counter while pointing a
gun at a woman who's taking in a scared
defensive position against the
refrigerator the people in the house all
look like new characters as far as we
can tell my best guess on this is that
the house is the same one that we saw
Dom out front of earlier it's probably
in New Jersey where her family lives so
this could be her family that Irving
brought up in season 3 during the finale
when he was convincing her that she had
no choice but to work with the dark army
the child who we see the men grabbing
looks like this actor who's listed as
playing a character named Tommy on the
shows I am d be paid
Irving mentioned that her youngest
family member was a four year old named
Jamie for speculations sake I'm guessing
this might be his older brother and that
the dark army is doing this to put
pressure on Tom at the very least this
looks like the same house she was
walking up to and we know she has a
brother with at least one child that
Irving threatened IMDB is pretty
unreliable but there are two kids listed
as playing Tommy and Jamie which are
both credited as being in two episodes
Jamie's the one that would be the four
year old I'm thinking Tommy might be his
brother I could be wrong but for now
that's what I think's going on here
either DOM did
something the dark army doesn't like or
she's refusing to cooperate so they are
in the process of sending her a message
the trailer and the voice-over end as we
see Elliot and mr. robot in front of a
fire in the woods
Elliot responds to mr. robots you're
crossing a line comment with it's a
little late for that don't you think the
fire is by no means a campfire it's
rather big we can't tell what he's
burning but it has the feeling that
Elliot is destroying evidence or perhaps
maybe even burning a car or something
along that I mean it's a big fire the
background looks wooded and snow-covered
similar to the shop where we saw Tyrell
walking earlier in the trailer all three
of them could be out in the woods
together which is a pretty good guess
and that's where it ends so there is a
lot of stuff in this one-minute trailer
with season 4 being longer than season 3
in the number of episodes I suppose that
makes sense
I mentioned mr. robots voice over being
interesting and that was the first thing
that stood out to me about this trailer
mr. robot is actually sounding like the
voice of reason here I know Sam SML
hinted that they would essentially have
to come together in statements that he
made after season 3 at the end of season
3 is really the first time we saw them
work together as a team after being at
odds all the time here standing in front
of the fire they actually look like
they're on the same page some of the
voice-over makes it sound like Elliot's
going to the extreme and that may be mr.
robots trying to bring him back a bit
how they get to that point and whether
mr. robot will have to bring Elliot back
from the edge after we're used to seeing
it go in the other direction remains to
be seen the other thing that stood out
to me was the shots of pretty much every
character looking concerned of course
it's not surprising that season 4 being
the final season wouldn't have some
serious and crazy moments but this
trailer gives like a dire feeling
everybody looks like the world is ending
and I guess the show is ending but yeah
they all look concerned in every shot
except for Vera and he's executing
somebody so he should actually
rightfully be concerned the whole thing
made me think that yeah this probably
ties into the whole idea but being along
Christmas special makes you think that
it could just be over a few days or
possibly maybe two weeks but either way
like 13 hours of show is going to be
condensed over a short period of time
so yeah the Angela stuff is a burning
question what's going on with the home
invasion what's going on at the scene
and where the man's
getting out next to the white roses
there's a lot of stuff that this trailer
didn't really touch on so what I'm
hoping is in the past we always see
another one and maybe like two weeks or
so right before the season starts so
hopefully we'll have another trailer to
fill us in with more information coming
soon I'm really excited like I said it's
been two years I can't take these long
breaks that they do and I wish it wasn't
the last season but I have a feeling
it'll all be worth the wait and this
trailer definitely gets me excited based
on what we see the little bit that we
see so far let me know in the comments
what you're thinking about what
questions that you have about where
we're at after season 3 what this
trailer brings up for you what you're
expecting to see in season 4 what you're
hoping the ending will turn out to be
let me know in the comments please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already I'll be making episode recaps
and possibly trailer breakdowns all
through the season like I have in the
past so definitely check back thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon